le mot d'ordre est donc solidarité
rester à la maison pour ne pas être
contaminé pour ne pas contaminer les
autres
nos reporters son parti à lyon là bas la
mesure de confinement semble être
respectée les rues sont presque désertes
une situation inédite pour les
commerçants luis carvalho et david
calife à la place bellecour vide et un
silence de cathédrale
du jamais vu en temps de paix dans la
capitale des gaules rues avenues
désertes commerces fermés en masse les
consignes de confinement sont respectées
à la lettre et les contrôles de police
sont quasi inexistants en partie dû à
une prise de conscience massive des
lyonnais rester chez eux pour les
commerçants qui restent ouverts comme ce
tabac en plein centre ville
la situation est inédite objectif pour
ce buraliste ne pas tomber dans la
sinistrose et rassurer au maximum sa
clientèle voilà paranoïa mais les gens
les gens ont besoin de parler
ils ont ils ont envie et besoin de
parler donc les peu de personnes que
jour par exemple comme aujourd'hui il ya
des discussions qui s'ouvrent sur des
sujets le sujet du coronavirus tous que
ça les préoccupations des gens ce que ce
que ça amène ce virus et les questions
qui se posent aussi d'où ça vient des
questions en suspens mais une réalité
effrayante pour les restaurants il faut
également s'adapter
seuls les livraisons sont autorisés à un
manque à gagner qui inquiète les
restaurateurs pas facile à gérer on
obligé de faire que du de la livraison
avec les les partenaires donc beaucoup
moins deux chiffres au jarret hristo
quel personnel mais qu'est ce qu'on peut
pour les livreurs l'inquiétude est
d'autant plus grande puisque la plupart
sont indépendants
même si le travail continue il est
évident que le confinement un impact
réel sur leurs revenus ou qui m'a
travaillé pour l'instant m
attention je vais voir comment la
situation a évolué pour l'instant je
suis indépendant en france donc se
travaille pas je gagne plus rien savoir
au deuxième jour de confinement millions
est à l'image d'une france qui commence
seulement à prendre conscience de la
gravité sanitaires à laquelle le monde
fait face